[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 26 minutes pour faire
le tour de l'actualité locale
tout de suite les titres de ce mercredi
26 septembre
quelles perspectives pour la politique
culturelle des yvelines le département a
fait le point ce matin avec les acteurs
de la culture du territoire c'était à
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines sur le site de guyancourt
entretien à suivre avec la vice
présidente du conseil départemental
joséphine coleman bergère un an qu'elle
était fermée amour pas pour raison de
sécurité d'église notre dame a rouvert
ses portes après des travaux effectués
dans la charpente une centaine de
fidèles à célébrer la nouvelle à
l'occasion de la messe du week-end
dernier
un office en présence de l'évêque de
pontoise enfin vous entendrez à la fin
de ce journal le brame du cerf tous les
ans à l'automne l'animal pousse son
fameux cri pour attirer les biches
l'espace rambouillet propose d'observer
ce rituel
mais avant de développer ses titres
faisant le point sur l'un des chantiers
en cours à saint quentin en yvelines
les travaux du nouveau centre commercial
de plaisir avance open sky devrait
ouvrir fin 2019
le projet se précise concernant les
commerces et enseignes qui investiront
le centre les détails de marilyn
iapichino et patrick jacques de dixmude
il commence à prendre forme les travaux
commencés en janvier 2017 avec la
démolition de l'ancienne zone
commerciale se poursuivre
le centre commercial open sky de plaisir
de 31 mille mètres carrés dévoile ses
premiers contours nos 120 train de
achever la structure sur le zone une
deux trois et quatre
nous allons attaquer la semaine
prochaine les travaux de structure de la
zone 5 le cinéma ugc
nous avons bouclé tous les appels
d'offres pour les lots clos couvert et
nous allons attaquer dans deux semaines
les appels d'offres pour les loges
une trentaine d'enseignants viendra
s'installer dans le centre avec
notamment la marque de prêt-à-porter à
bas prix pride marquent encore peu
présente en france
elle occupera ici une zone entière sur
deux étages mais cette offre mode sera
également complétée par une véritable
offre de restauration et ça c'est
important parce que ça va avec cette
notion de lieu de vie de retrouver des
terrasses de retrouver un des lieux pour
consommer entre amis au moment du
shopping
autre point fort d'open sky un
multiplexe de neuf salles de cinéma ugc
une offre de septième art qui manquait à
la commune de plaisir faut savoir que
nous créons donc 1200 places de cinéma
c'était une attente sur le territoire à
la fois une attente du public mais aussi
une attente des professionnels qui
aimerait renforcer le maillage en termes
de cinéma sur le territoire et je
rappelle quand même que le cinéma est
aujourd'hui la sortie culturelle préféré
des français et donc nous sommes
contents de pouvoir accueillir ici
une offre complémentaire à celle qui
existe déjà sur le territoire
le chantier continue son avancée
ouverture prévue fin 2010 9
le centre commercial devrait permettre
la création de 300 à 400 emplois
elle est justement maire de plaisir et
animer une réunion toute la matinée a lu
vs qu joséphine coleman ce berger convié
les acteurs de la culture et des
territoires de versailles et saint
quentin en yvelines premier rendez vous
d'une série de trois réunions avec la
vice présidente du conseil départemental
l'objectif c'est de présenter le bilan
les évolutions et perspectives en
matière de politique culturelle
regardez cet entretien les images sont
signés marylène iapichino joséphine
coleman verger bonjour vous êtes vice
présidente du conseil départemental des
yvelines en charge de la culture du
tourisme et de l'environnement alors
vous teniez ce matin une réunion auprès
des acteurs culturels du territoire les
territoires de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
et et de versailles et ses réunions en
fait c'est cette réunion ce matin
c'était la première d'un cycle de trois
réunions où vous allez aller à la
rencontre des acteurs culturels pour
leur présenter le bilan en termes de
culture et aussi les perspectives
pourquoi pourquoi ces réunions ces
réunions sont fondamentales vous savez
il y a deux ans nous avons mis en place
de nouveaux dispositifs culturel qui
était un véritable changement sur le
département puisque nous étions dans un
mode de fonctionnement d'accompagnement
au niveau justement du fonctionnement et
aujourd'hui nous sommes en mode projet
qui n'a rien d'original puisque même les
équipements même la politique je dirais
territoriale aujourd'hui fonctionne de
cette manière
donc je rappelais ce matin lors de cette
réunion qu'il était important de se
remémorer cette période line la
difficulté que ça a été j'ai même
employer le mot d'un peu brutale puisque
ça a été fait avec une grande rapidité
difficile à supporter parfois par nos
partenaires
mais tout au long de ces deux années
nous avons fait un accompagnement très
sérieux pour la compréhension des
nouveaux dispositifs
mais nous avons surtout écoutez vous
l'avez rappelé vous même nous avons
surtout voulu développer un bilan pour
voir effectivement ce qui allait et ce
qui n'allait pas et comment on aurait pu
un peu je dirais modifié
et assouplir tous ces dispositifs nous
avons fait une étude en interne bien sûr
avec les agents et avec nos partenaires
et nous avons fait aussi une étude que
nous avons confié à l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines et
nous avons travaillé que des chercheurs
est d'ailleurs au mois de novembre nous
présenteront le bilan définitif des
chercheurs ce qui nous a permis au moins
de juin 2018 et bien au conseil
départemental d'apporter des
modifications des allégements les
pérennisation sur les nouveaux
dispositifs qui sont pas tout à fait
nouveau mais qui sont arrangées avec le
vote d'une nouvelle politique culturelle
exactement elle est pas nouvelle elle
est adaptée je vais dire aux territoires
et donc nous avons décidé de faire ces
trois grandes réunions donc une ici à
saint quentin en yvelines
et puis une à rambouillet et une à
chanteloup les vignes pour pouvoir
présenter justement ces nouveaux
dispositifs
je dirais plus adaptées peut-être dans
la tente de nos partenaires tel est le
rôle d'un département comme les yvelines
dans le développement culturel jeu ce
qui est important pour un département
c'est de penser à l'ensemble de la
population c'est de penser à tous les
territoires avec cette diversité aussi
importante que qui est celle du
département des yvelines qui va de la
grande ruralité à l'urbanisation totale
et c'est pas simple d'avoir un
développement culturelle équilibrée et
puis aussi nous avons toute une
population qui est une population
empêchée vers laquelle nous devons aller
et c'est un peu dans ce sens là que nous
avons je dirais à porter ces nouveaux
dispositifs pour aller vers cette vraie
dynamique et puis surtout démontré aussi
que le département des yvelines est déjà
riche d'un potentiel culturel que le
département n'a pas du tout envie
d'abandonner bien au contraire
ce matin je peux vous le dire le retour
que nous avons eue c'est une
compréhension actuellement et une mise
en application de ce mode projet avec
une chose le dire une sérénité et
hameaux qui que je leur ai demandé de
réévaluer c'est le mot confiance
puisqu'il ya deux ans c'était un peu
compliqué aussi présenté trois exemples
de soutien du sud de soutien du
département sur des événements aussi des
salles notamment le festival de la bd de
but qu'un classique chaque année qui va
arriver le 6 et 7 octobre
oui tout à fait je pense qu'il était
important que des partenaires viennent
montrer des choses concrètes
parce que vous savez ça paraît toujours
un petit peu intellectualiser les
dispositifs et les explications
là nous avons eu effectivement entre
autres le festival de la bd de buc qui à
démontrer l'apport du département sur
sur un développement qu'ils ont pu faire
dans les prisons par exemple et sur un
public en petit empêcher mais bien
évidemment ça ne va pas que là puisqu'il
ya des dispositifs sur l'investissement
il ya des dispositifs sur des
manifestations qui rayonne sur certains
territoires alors au 1er janvier
il ya une évolution dans le cadre
d'intervention du département en matière
de de développement culturel qu'est ce
que ça va changer concrètement cette
évolution au 1er janvier
ça va changer que bah déjà je voulais 10
au niveau de ce rapport au département
de cette confiance qu'il est rétabli je
pense eh bien on va voir émerger encore
plus de projets sur le territoire alors
loin de moi l'idée de dire qu'ils
avaient besoin du département pour avoir
des projets il avait déjà énormément de
projets mais je pense que ça insuffler
un développement supplémentaire et
surtout un partenariat et des mises en
réseau beaucoup plus développé que nous
souhaitons accompagner si ça qui fait le
rayonnement du département
on a une spécificité des sifi cité par
dow au niveau du département qui est pas
forcément je dirais une culture vitrine
mais une culture implanter une culture
profonde avec des je dirais des
opérateurs et avec des partenaires de
grande qualité dont nous sommes très
fiers dans les budgets quand on doit
faire des économies c'est vrai qu'on a
tendance à dire que la culture trinque
en général là pour le département des
evil et quelles sont les perspectives
pour les prochains mois les prochaines
années en termes culturels
je vais pas rappeler la baisse énorme
que nous avons eues il y a deux ans pour
toutes les raisons vous connaissez sur
lesquels je vais pas revenir mais enfin
les baisses de dotations quand même
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut peut-être
rappeler mais il est clair que le budget
aujourd'hui n'est pas un budget en
baisse par rapport aux années qui
viennent c'est un budget que l'on
souhaite constant mieux utiliser
mieux répartie avec je dirais cette
intelligente de territoire qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui nos partenaires en aucune
façon ne nous ont demandé si on allait
augmenter le budget donc ça veut dire
que quelque part pas tout le monde n'est
pas forcément dans satisfait de
l'accompagnement au niveau financier
peut-être mais en tout cas je peux vous
dire que ce matin on est vraiment
rassuré moi je suis d'abord ravi et
enchanté de voir le travail qui a été
fait par les agents du département qui
ont fait un travail colossal de
proximité pour accompagner justement
cette nouvelle politique et je pense que
cette politique telle que nous l'avons
mise en place fera des petits et des
adeptes dans d'autres départements
merci joséphine coleman berger je
rappelle que vous êtes vice présidente
du conseil départemental en charge de la
culture du tourisme et de
l'environnement
un entretien enregistré ce matin à
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines l agglomération
saint-quentinoise et son golf national
qui reçoivent en ce moment bien sûr la
ryder cup la compétition officielle
débute vendredi mais l'événement a déjà
commencé avec le tournoi des célébrités
hier et la suite des entraînements des
joueurs
aujourd'hui mercredi le président de
saint quentin en yvelines a accueilli
les journalistes présents pendant
l'événement ils sont environ 1000 à être
accrédité sur cette coupe du monde de
golf et jean michel fourgous a tenu a
rappelé dans son discours les capacités
du territoire à accueillir de grands
rendez-vous propos collectées par
patrick jacques de dixmude et michael et
demi d'euros c'est évident que
l'événement est exceptionnel c'est la
première fois que la ryder cup d'abord
vie en france
c'est la première fois en plus dans dans
les yvelines je vous rappelle qu'à 30
il ya trois golfs à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines donc c'est une
c'est une petite capitale maintenant
aujourd'hui golfique
il ya 30 golf dans les yvelines
effectivement ça département très vert
aussi qui se prête bien est un des plus
mais surperformance et celui là donc
très fier bien sûr cette triple
reconnaissance puisque beaucoup de
maintenant de manifestations dont les
jeux olympiques derrière se mettre en
avant ce territoire et ne manquez pas
ces rendez vous tous les soirs jusqu'à
dimanche sur tv 78 émission spéciale
ryder cup pour revenir sur les
principaux événements de la journée ce
soir à 18h45 vous retrouverez à nouveau
depuis le golf national nickel et demi
d'euros et patrick jacques de dixmude
avec au programme ce soir les produits
dérivés de la ryder cup la ryder cup
aussi des juniors la compétition pour
les jeunes une rediffusion de l'émission
à 19h45 et 23h15 ainsi que sur notre
site internet tv 78 points comme
toujours à saint quentin en yvelines le
ski cub a organisé récemment une
rencontre autour de l'open innovation et
de l'open data est deux facteurs de
l'innovation et du développement
économique des entreprises des échanges
entre différents acteurs de
l'agglomération pour partager les bonnes
expériences reportage de nicolas d'andré
la mise en place de l'open innovation et
l'open data dans une entreprise la
thématique d'une rencontre organisée au
ski cube partage des expériences
notamment avec le groupe segula
spécialisée dans l'ingénierie et le
développement de projets industriels
une entreprise basée à trappes est
implantée dans 26 pays
l'open innovation pour nous c'est le
dire est une façon un mode de travail
qui nous permet un d'accélérer
l'innovation et 2 d'augmenter en
compétences rapidement l'innovation
c'est aussi une animation j'irai pour
pour stimuler collaborateurs et
recueillir leurs idées donc une
autorisation le permet aujourd'hui créer
un réseau entre ses salariés ses clients
ou d'autres entreprises le principe de
l'open innovation une pratique mise en
place chez renault exemple avec les open
innovation lab un travail avec des
acteurs externes au groupe au losange
c'est le fait de dire qu'on va
rassembler autour d'une même table des
acteurs qu'on va plaider qu acteur et
qui vont construire ensemble des des
solutions vous avez edf vous avez plein
de start up et de grosses entreprises
qui se rend compte sur un même sujet là
en l'occurrence et la mobilité et
ensuite la deuxième chose si vous avez
les creative lab c'est plutôt les labels
interne et la cde je dirais de l'open
innovation interne
parmi la trentaine de participants
nabila ali ingénieur en génie civil
à moyen terme il souhaite créer son
entreprise en développant un outils
destinés au btp avec des enjeux autour
de l'open innovation et l'open data
c'est une problématique qui est ressenti
par les territoires que ce soit des
communautés d'agglomération ou des
entreprises est une question qui est de
plus en plus importante et qui nous
touche nous particulièrement dans le btp
prochain rendez vous au ski cube le
mardi 9 octobre à 17h30 pour la welcome
party une soirée pour découvrir les
services offerts par le territoire
inscription obligatoire auprès du ski
cube un camion en tournée dans toute la
france et qui a fait escale à versailles
la cci des yvelines vient d'accueillir
le foehn trucks et un véhicule dans
lequel les entrepreneurs monde pour
présenter leurs projets à des
investisseurs un jury nomme ensuite le
lauréat
marylène iapichino et mélanie poker cet
homme ne cherche pas à vendre deux
sandwiches mais un projet trois minutes
pour convaincre un jury de potentiels
investisseurs c'est le principe de foehn
traque lancée par la plateforme de
financement des start up so we found
il y a quatre ans cette compétition
permet de donner un coup de pouce à des
entrepreneurs en recherche de
financement l'objectif c'est de
permettre à des entrepreneurs de pitcher
devant un parterre d'investisseurs
composés de jurys investisseurs son
investissement réseaux de business
angels mais également membre des
écosystèmes et grands comptes pour
pouvoir créer un maximum de relation le
funk rock s'est déjà rendu dans cinq
régions dénicher ces finalistes pour
cette édition francilienne 200
entrepreneurs ont envoyé leur
candidature
seuls cinq d'entre eux ont le privilège
de se présenter dans le camion et
argumenter leurs projets face au jury il
y en a pas besoin d'être d'avoir une
fortune énorme pour faire la courte
échelle à des projets à fort
développement à fort potentiel un
exercice qui ne s'arrête pas là durant
la journée lequel on fera deux autres
étapes à la défense puis au ministère
des finances de bercy
au total ce sont une trentaine d'acteurs
de l'écosystème que les candidats vont
pouvoir rencontrer faut trouver comment
dire l'essentiel
et puis puis après il est question c'est
assez pratique de développer lors des
questions réponses
c'est surtout ça qu'on attend nous on
préfère je pense le format un peu
interactifs smart rennes team une agence
immobilière spécialisée dans la sous
location a remporté cette étape
régionale
il gagne son ticket pour la grande
finale le 15 novembre prochain
pas de financement à la clé prévu parfum
de troc mais une visibilité garantie
pour le vainqueur
c'est un métier qui après 2000 ans
d'histoire notaire une activité à
porteuse d'emplois le lycée toulouse
lautrec de vaucresson a accueilli une
rencontre entre élèves de bts notariat
et le président du conseil régional des
notaires de versailles nicolas landry
était sur place
travailler dans une étude notariale
c'est la vocation choisi par ses 200
étudiants en bts notariat
ils viennent des lycée marie curie de
versailles ou toulouse-lautrec de
vaucresson particularité de ce dernier
établissement l'accueil d'élèves en
situation de handicap moteur et au cours
des stages si on à g
j'ai pu avoir beaucoup de contacts avec
la clientèle et ça va beaucoup intéressé
et du coup ça m'a sava ouvert vers les
autres j'ai toujours eu cette envie
d'aller en notariat et c'est un oui
c'est un milieu que j'aime beaucoup qui
relève du droit j'ai vécu des
expériences en devant des notaires en
tant que client avec surtout mes grands
parents et mes parents et je voulais et
je voulais découvrir ce métier
le droit me plaît énormément car
j'estime que ben on en a besoin dans la
vie quotidienne tous les jours bts
notariat une formation post bac de deux
ans des cours de droit de déontologie ou
de culture générale pour devenir notaire
claire ou encore rédacteur d'actes c'est
l'occasion de leur présenter ce qu'est
la profession ce que sont les métiers
qui sont proposés au sein de nos études
et puis quelques traits caractéristiques
de notre profession notamment l'impact
fort de la déontologie autres qu'au
travers donc de cette de cette formation
il est 12 offrons bon nombre d'emplois
et bon nombre également de perspectives
de carrière avec de nombreux métiers et
des évolutions possibles les métiers du
notariat représente environ 2700 emplois
sur le territoire de la cour d'appel de
versailles dont près de 1000 dans les
yvelines selon la bourse de l'emploi du
notariat près de 30 postes sont à
pourvoir actuellement dans le
département c'est votre fil rouge depuis
le début de la semaine deux ans le 7 8
journal le dossier de la rédaction sur
l'alimentation de nos enfants à l'école
après les lycées universités suite ce
soir dans les cantines des collèges géré
par le département
ces établissements vont connaître au 1er
janvier 2019 un nouveau mode de
fonctionnement
alors comment fonctionne actuellement
ses cantines éléments de réponse à bois
d'arcy avec nicolas landry il est 10
heures dans la cuisine du collège mozart
de bois d'arcy cathy gastrin chef de
cuisine prépare un beurre blanc une
sauce pour accompagner le dos de
cabillaud ou la côte de veau avec des
pommes de terre le menu destiné aux 600
élèves de l'établissement une réduction
de vin blanc avec de riches à
ensuite qu'on monte au beurre avec du
beurre bref c'est pour accompagner le
poisson qui est adoptée bio aujourd'hui
avec des pommes de terre à la vapeur
pour mon travail avec le conseil
départemental sur une plateforme
on choisit nos produits là entre autres
c'est du surgelé
parce qu'en collectivité en grosse
quantité
le surgelé tri sur le frappe de cuisine
ont au maximum parce que c'est ce qui va
faire baisser une
coupe repartent le fait des peluches et
des carottes le matin et de déraper sur
place ça nous arrive de faire des
salades des deux lentilles au lieu de
faire une vinaigrette normal base de
moutarde
bah on va faire une vinaigrette à base
d'oeufs d'huile de noisette et de
vinaigre de pomme cuisinés sur place
avec des produits livrés tous les deux
jours cette personne travaille aux côtés
de la chef de cuisine pour l'aider
notamment à recevoir les livraisons il
ya de la civette des tomates de la
menthe fraîche et du persil parce que
moi prévus au menu un taboulé libanais
les yvelines consacre 40 6 millions
d'euros pour la restauration scolaire
avec des modes de fonctionnement
différent entre les 116 cantines des
collèges yvelinois aujourd'hui le
département souhaite harmoniser sa
gestion avec la création d'une société
d'économie mixte à opération unique les
deux tiers du capital de cette société
seront détenus par l'entreprise qui va
avoir la responsabilité de la
fabrication mais elle ne sera pas
délégataire comme on le fait aujourd'hui
c'est à dire elle décide de tout tout
seul
nous serons actionnaires minoritaires
donc le département en tant
qu'institution présidera le conseil
d'admistration on surveillera cette
société pour s'assurer que la qualité
l'écoutent
tout choix bien cadré est bien conforme
au cahier des charges
plusieurs garanties comme l'utilisation
de 20 % de produits bio le respect de la
saisonnalité ou encore le suivi de la
traçabilité des denrées
la réforme sera mise en oeuvre au 1er
janvier 2019
et parmi les entreprises sodexo elior
sont candidates pour prendre en charge
la restauration scolaire des collèges
yvelinois le choix doit être fait ce
vendredi 28 septembre lors d'une séance
au conseil départemental
je vous en parlais dans les titres de ce
journal l'église notre-dame de maurepas
a rouvert cet été les dix fils était
fermé depuis un an suite à des fissures
dans la charpente et l'événement a été
fêté ce dimanche lors d'une messe puis
avec une grande kermesse
isabelle caris co
ils étaient des centaines de fidèles à
la grande messe de rentrée pour célébrer
sa réouverture
l'église notre dame de l'espérance a
repris vie ce dimanche à maurepas
c'était un moment d'émotion vraiment
vraiment fort parce que moi j'ai rêvé la
dernière l'église venait de fermer
il a fallu voilà à prendre des décisions
pour essayer de faire face à la
conjoncture et là un an après pour
commencent tous ensemble et par rossi a
vraiment envie de se retrouver après un
an de travaux et de fermeture
l'édifice religieux avait rouvert ses
portes aux fidèles depuis la mi juillet
il ya beaucoup de gens qui viennent
officiellement de pays
d'ailleurs qui ont pour qui l'église
c'est vraiment faire le bâtiment et 10 c
en le centre du village c'est tout le
monde se retrouveront ils passent la
journée on joue au foot dehors en
afrique au brésil moi j'étais au brésil
et l'a donc ces populations là elles
sont très heureuses parce que l'élysée
ont été fermés babre gens sont à pied
aller dans les petites églises un peu
loin c'est difficile là on voit beaucoup
de gens venir enfin c'est grisant le
matin mais devant la porte de lille on
va les gens arrivés à pied de partout à
travers la place et on se retrouve voilà
tout ça l'office a été célébré avec
émotion par monseigneur stanislas
lalanne évêque de pontoise et ancien
curé de la paroisse pour moi c'est
impressionnant parce que j'ai été
écoeurée jusqu'à 2,94 à 99 ça fait
presque vingt ans et puis je retrouve
beaucoup de visages connus et puis dans
mon ministère de prêtre
ces cinq ans ont été demandés ça a été
magnifique que la communauté vivante
elle est ouverte aux autres la messe a
été suivie d'une kermesse ouvre pas et
boissons attendait les fidèles pour
cette journée riche en nouveautés les
paroissiens ont également fêté leurs
nouveaux saints patrons notre dame de
l'espérance
on referme ce journal en forêt de
rambouillet où tous les ans pour la
saison des amours l'essai recherche
l'attention des biches l espace
rambouillet propose des balades pour
observer écouter le fameux bram la
parade nuptiale de ses serres marylène
iapichino et isabelle carrasco ont pu
observer ce rituel pour le cerf le mois
de septembre c'est le début de la saison
des amours
alors pour faire des rencontres ils
donnent de la voix
nous entendons drame où c'est le cri
poussé pain ne sert donc le mal pour
défier des autres serres est aussi
séduire les niches est tous les ans à
cette période de l'année à savoir entre
mi septembre début octobre
c'est la période de reproduction de
l'espèce le cerf et durant cette période
va pousser ce cri fameux on appelle le
bramont s'il sait se faire remarquer des
biches il se montre plus timide avec
l'humain dans la forêt de rambouillet
c'est pas facile de les rencontrer à
cette époque de l'année vous avez d
antan et l'avantagent à l'espace
rambouillet c'est que le dispositif
installé permettent de les voir avec
quasi certitude
lors des visites que l'organisme
l'espace rambouillet propose des visites
en autonomie mais aussi des moments
spéciaux le matin ou le soir sur
réservation
et bien c'est très prisé effectivement
est là pour cette année on est
pratiquement à 100 % de réservations
ici les gens sont encore intéressés ils
peuvent venir y assister en journée en
toute liberté
ne reste plus qu'à penser à prendre sa
paire de jumelles et se montrer discret
pour peut-être apercevoir coup de foudre
entre cervidés c'est la fin de ce
journal je vous rappelle ce rendez-vous
à suivre ce soir sur tv 78 à 18h45
émission spéciale ryder cup depuis le
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et miquel et
demi d'euros en compagnie de patrick
jacques de dixmude reviendront sur les
principaux événements de la journée
notamment les produits dérivés de cette
ryder cup 2018 ils parleront également
de la ryder cup des juniors une
compétition pour les jeunes rediffusion
de cette émission à 19h45 23h15
également sur notre site internet tv 78
points comme et puis dans un instant
nouveau numéro du 7-8 débat présenté par
isabelle karas causse le thème ce soir
c'est la fin du numerus clausus dans les
études de médecine belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]